the Turkish public health system has
collapsed here in iskandarin the Indian
army is filling the gap
its field Hospital in a school is the
only health facility serving a
pre-earthquake population of a quarter
of a million people initially we had
dramas loss of loss of lymph head and
chest traumas patients who were buried
in the rubble we had to do an amputation
to Save a Life of a patient its leg was
gangrenous then finally we have saved
stabilized him and moved him to Adana
now the patient profile is changing and
now gradually more of the infectious
diseases are coming in
the Turkish government has struggled to
cope with the disaster of this scale
so its citizens are relying on aid from
across the world
on the morning of the Quake hamedi
sarach says everywhere was hell
who's going to die and I
know what we'll do
there was another Tremor just a moment
ago and we're outside the public
Hospital opposite the school is in too
dangerous a condition to consider
reopening
with more than a million people homeless
across Southeastern turkey many living
in tents there's an increased risk of a
widespread outbreak of disease
the Indian army says it'll only consider
leaving turkey when the number of
patients is treating begins to level off
there's no sign of that happening now
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera iskandra